une nouvelle révolution technologique
pour internet les opérateurs donnent le
coup d'envoi du très haut débit une
puissance 30 fois supérieur qui permet
d'utiliser internet d'être au téléphone
de regarder la télévision tout cela en
même temps sans saturation
isabelle quintard mathias secondes il
vous est sans doute arrivé de vouloir
télécharger une bande annonce sur
internet
voilà ce que cela donne entre 1h40 et
2h26 d'attentes quand on a un bas débit
aujourd'hui on nous annonce l'arrivée de
l'ultra haut débit avec cette
technologie les délais d'attentes vont
quasiment disparaître
démonstration avec un spécialiste cette
vidéo libres de droits le site qui la
propose précise qu'avec un abonnement
bas débit on télécharge en 22 minutes
avec un abonnement adsl traditionnelle
en deux minutes et demie pour
télécharger ce film en utilisant ma
freebox et la csl le plus l'accès aux
films est instantané il y a dix ans la
vitesse sur internet s'élevait à 56 kg
beat secondes
il y a cinq ans dépasser à 512 kilobits
secondes et maintenant voici quinze
megabit seconde l'air de l'ultra haut
débit l'astuce allait finalement assez
simple à savoir que le signal internet
était diffusé dans une zone déterminée
on a doublé cette zone donc le signal
peut être beaucoup plus puissant pour
les 11 millions d'internautes français
cela veut dire la possibilité de surfer
à vitesse grand v et pour les
fournisseurs d'accès une concurrence
acharnée le 1er décembre à paris france
télécom devrait à son tour proposé le
très haut débit alors